I was doing a lot of rescue work I was a
peace officer for the state of New York
for the league for animal protection I
remember going getting called in to
where a dog was being really abused a
pit bull was being really abused uh at
this at this location somewhere on Long
Island I'm not going to give you the
location so I go there about 10 11
o'clock at night I knock on the door
needs to be grubby looking guys to
answer the door right out of a biker
movie and they say yeah what do you want
they said well I got a complaint about
your uh your dog being abused and they
said who are you and I said I'm with the
animal league for protection he said
you're a dog cop
you're a dog cop so then then and it was
it was a motorcycle gang I'll mention
their name with the pagans a big Club on
the East Coast very very aggressive club
and we started talking they knew I was
in the military and after that
confrontation we started smoking we
joined together I trained the dog we
became good friends but
it was all worked out it all worked out
so it started getting a little notoriety
you know I started training some
Mobsters dogs you know Carlo Gambino in
a lot of Gambino's dogs yeah yeah